They did
file a statement
of facts
in addition to this barebones indictment.
The indictment itself doesn't talk about
whether or not the what
crime was relied upon
to pump it up
from a misdemeanor to a felony.
But it is but there is language
in by way of a statement of facts
that was also filed
along with the indictment,
which is indictment number 71543 of 23 23
is with respect to the year 2023.
And there's an introduction
that talks about how Donald Trump
this is again the statement of facts,
how Donald Trump
repeatedly and fraudulently falsified
business records
to conceal criminal conduct
that hid damaging information
from the voting public during the 2016
presidential election.
So right from the outside.
This is
this is all about election interference
and that's how they're framing it.
Then it says from about August 2015
to December 2017
the defendant orchestrated
a scheme with others
to influence the 2016 president
presidential election
by identifying and purchasing
negative information about him
to suppress its publication
and benefit the defendant's
electoral prospects.
And it says in order to execute
this unlawful scheme
the participants violated election laws
and made and caused
false entries
in the business
records of various entry
entities in New York.
So so the DA's office here is relying on
election laws
as the crimes
that were being either
concealed or committed
to elevate
the falsifying business records
to a felony.
It says one component of the scheme
was that at the defendant's request,
a lawyer
who then worked
for the Trump Organization
as special counsel to the
to the defendant,
they're calling him a lawyer,
a covertly paid $130,000
to an adult film actress
shortly before the election.
So this is talking
Michael Michael Cohen
paying Stormy Daniels $130,000.
It then goes on
to describe how that's done
and the false business records
that are used
or that were created to conceal
the payment.
So after the election,
this lawyer then goes on to
they describe how each check
was processed
and disguised
for payment of legal services.
Is each check a separate account?
Yes.
Each check
appears to be a separate account.
Some of them.
Some of these there
were invoices,
and that would be, as Adam
Coffey was saying earlier, each entry
of false information into a business
record would be its own count.
And so
each each item has its own account.
The statement of fact then goes on
and talks about a background
There's a section called Background.
Before that was the introduction,
and it talks about the Trump
Organization
from approximately June 20, 15
and to 2017.
And, and then it talks about a scheme
they call the scheme
and they call it the catch
and kill scheme to suppress
negative information.
And then it goes on and gives
very detailed facts.
There was a Trump Tower
meeting at 22 in 2015
and then it says a few months later
they tried to suppress a doorman's story.
And there's just
a lot of information in here
that that we'd love to digest
and come back and tell.
But this is statement of facts
that was filed by the district
attorney's office is to tell Mr.
Trump
first and
foremost and his legal team
what evidence was presented
to a grand jury
and what will be relied upon at trial
and what will be proven at trial.
I just want to go to CNN's
Kara Scannell,
who's gotten out of the courtroom.
Describe just what you heard
and saw in court
as we continue
to look over into the indictments
Well, Anderson,
when the former president entered
the courtroom, you could hear a pin drop.
He entered,
he scanned each and every row
filled with reporters.
And he had a bit of a scowl on his face.
He walked very slowly
to the defense table.
And then he didn't speak
until the judge asked him to enter a plea
on those 34 counts.
Of falsifying business records
in the first degree.
And the former president said
in his voice that we all know not guilty.
Now, the judge,
the prosecutors also asked the judge
to address
the rhetoric that former president
has made,
both by the verbal attacks
he's placed on the judge,
as well as the district attorney,
Alvin Bragg.
And the judge
said that, you know,
he was concerned about these statements.
An attorney for Donald Trump,
Todd Bland, who just came onto the team.
He said that Trump was frustrated
and that he has not had a chance
to address
all of these allegations
that the prosecution
and their witnesses,
including Michael Cohen,
have gone out and publicly spoken about.
Now, the judge said that he did not agree
that this was justified by frustration,
and he said he would warn both sides,
both the prosecution
and Donald Trump,
to tamp down their rhetoric.
He wasn't going to impose
any kind of gag order.
But he also warned them that they needed
to address this to tamp down
and not incite any violence.
I'm a little out of breath
because I had to ride around the block
because the security is so tight here
to get out of the building. Right.
Take some breath.
But that was basically it from
the president. He didn't
he he wasn't asked
really any other questions to engage,
which is normal in an arraignment.
There's really just a little engagement
from the actual defendant.
I think we see him
and his motorcade leaving now. The.